和我的前夫，
我们俩都是低势力人群，
以那个中医那个什么什么什么拿为生，
然后一个月工资差不多就就五六千左右，
他比我大十岁，
我现在是24岁就父子结婚了，
我妈妈是不同意的，
我觉得我我整个婚姻都是错误的，
刚开始呢，
我们虽然是同一个省份的，
但是相差距离特别远嘛，
他们那边的彩礼就是最多是8万，
然后一般都是三万六万，
然后女方会返回一，
就是会返回双倍的嫁妆，
我们那边的彩礼呢，
就是最低8万，
一般都是十万12万这个样子，
然后他说给6万彩礼行不行，
我觉得就是我结婚这件事情已经这么叛逆了，
我就不想让我妈妈再为这个彩礼的事情，
就这么样子嘛，
我妈妈要8万嘛，
然后我就跟他商量，
他也同意了，
我妈妈本来说答应这个8万块钱，
当时说给我带过去的，
后面他又说想留着以后我们买房子的时候再全部给我嘛，
刚结婚了之后，
我老公就说我妈妈是骗子，
我们是骗子，
这个就是我感觉就是错误的开始就这个，
他有心结，
怀孕的时候就是因为这个事情吵架，
我有想过就是刚开始就这样子，
是不是应该结束，
我有想过离开，
但是他又求和，
然后。
我又继续跟他一起生活了，
在院子里也是因为这件事情闹了，
我当时是真的想走，
我说嗯，
彩礼钱全部退给你，
然后孩子也是你的，
我明天就走了。
她又求和，
后面因为口罩之后，
嗯，
他才告诉我他那个什么崩了，
就是已经变成了黑名黑黑黑用户了，
我后面才知道她结婚彩礼包括生孩子的钱都是套的，
我当时心里有点想法，
但是也觉得没什么，
就一起吃吃苦呗。
第二年还是第三年，
我又因为电信诈骗也被骗了4万块钱，
他对我这个也有很大的那个意见，
我知道这这件事情是我的不对，
然后从此以后就是因为也是她的赚钱，
公公婆婆不帮忙带孩子，
我就全职带孩子，
就什么都听他的，
然后尽量把姿态放低，
就顺着他，
我选择离开的原因是因为他每年都在说那种话，
而且越来越过分。
刚开始是说为我结婚生孩子花了几十万，
是不是我把他害成这个样子的？
都是我每次都是因为一件很小很小的事情就爆发了，
他说请问你这四五年来赚过一分钱吗？
你凭什么用这种态度跟老子说话？
再到今年又是因为一个很小的事情，
他说你这些年吃了老子的，
喝了老子的，
还天天像个神经病一样。
我当时真的忍不住，
我就爆发了。
呃，
我就叫我妈妈把我接过来了，
现在就是分开的状态，
然后呢，
她现在求和的态度很好，
反正她看的样子是挺伤心的，
我妈妈他们都心软的，
但是给他又跪下来求我们，
我还是没有心软，
现在我孩子也是跟我们一样的问题，
需要做长期的视力康复训练，
我现在一个人带着他，
我妈妈在帮我带，
我在上班，
我不知道我该不该回去，
或者说我以后该怎么办，
我问你啊，
嗯，
第一你是，
呃，
家里面还有兄弟吗？
我有一个哥哥嫂子，
她那个怀孕了，
你妈妈那个8万块钱的那个彩礼最后给你了吗？
因为孩子手术嘛，
做了几次手术，
就是每次手术的时候都会拿出来给我们一点，
差不多陆陆续续给了四五万了，
他也知道，
我老公知道孩子是男孩女孩呀，
女女孩现在四岁半啊，
四岁半他已经如果要呃康复，
恢复像正常人一样的视力的话，
呃，
医生有慢病机会有多大，
或者说要花多少钱啊，
这个很难说，
但是肯定就是在大概12岁之前，
就是要不停的这样子，
不停的这样子一年差不多，
我们花在市面上面的钱一年差不多两三万，
因为我们之间有一个补贴，
是因为我们双方有残疾证嘛，
有一个补贴是孩子就是国那个什么给。
孩子的抚抚养费补贴我，
他找我谈抚养费的意思就是他要把这笔钱算在抚养费里面，
因为这笔钱从从去年开始，
我们手头有一点点宽裕之后，
就把他存起来了，
想给孩子留着以后的备用资金差不多有2万块钱左右，
还有我把这个钱花掉了之后，
才愿意每个月给1000块钱，
你的爸爸妈妈现在对你带回来这个女儿好不好啊，
挺好的，
我尤其是我嫂子真的特别特别特别好，
哎，
现在这种情况下，
你回到娘家的时候，
还能找一个像那种推拿按摩的那个班儿上吗？
我在上班，
我每个月就是我算了呢，
每个月我可以拿4000工资，
就是淡季的时候4000没问题，
然后夏天可能就六七千也可以，
然后再加上国家上的补贴，
我日子是能过的，
这个小孩那个2万块钱的补贴或者补花的是每年都有吗？
每年都有到孩子18岁，
如果说孩子18岁以后继续上学的话，
也是有的。
啊，
大概一个月是花八百，
八百一千吗？
还是怎么的，
嗯，
差不多就一千一千，
哦，
那挺好的，
嗯，
那也就是说你其实回娘家了之后，
嫂子人也很好，
爸爸妈妈对你的孩子也很好，
其实你是有退路的，
对，
因为我要离之前，
我就我也看了你的直播嘛，
我就想了很多的，
我认真的跟我哥哥嫂子他们商量，
我说这个日子我如果要过也是能过的，
但是我现在内心确实是不想过，
很抵触，
我说你们也，
嗯，
我过来肯定是有负担的，
就是你们也好好商量一下，
然后咱们商量一下，
然后我嫂子说要不你就直接回来吧，
别委屈自己，
然后他们都支持我。
嗯，
小姨真好，
在我家里老师真很好，
嗯，
那像你这种情况，
你现在纠结的问题是什么，
需要龙飞姐帮你分析的问题是什么呢？
我感觉后面还会回来求和我，
我要不要为了就是给孩子一个完整的家庭再回去，
他那边家人说他又不，
呃，
不，
我不加什么的，
坦率的讲，
他之所以很在乎那8万块钱的彩礼钱没有带回去，
就是因为从一开始他也骗了你啊，
对吧，
他没，
他没有告诉你，
他这个彩礼钱是可能是借的，
可能是网贷的，
可能是对吧，
凑来的，
他也欺骗了你啊，
是的，
他骗了我，
然后你你爸爸妈妈这一头，
并不是因为重男轻女把这个钱挪用了给你的哥哥去花了，
而是因为确实是在你女儿治病的这个过程当中，
这钱也陆陆续续又花到你女儿治病这件事情上去了，
对不对？
是的是的，
他也知道，
每次转过来我也告诉他了，
他也知道你跟他生活在一起，
和你现在跟爸爸妈妈，
跟哥哥嫂嫂生活在一起，
你认真观察一下女儿在哪边更快乐，
更开心，
感觉他的开心程度是差不多的，
就可能在这边出他的人多嘛，
然后就小脾气会多一点，
你自己在哪里更开心呢？
我自己现在更开心。
啊，
那就遵从自己的内心吧，
如果说这边娘家爸爸妈妈，
包括你的嫂子对孩子都很好是吧，
这边心情也很好，
对对，
对于孩子来说，
妈妈的心情最关键，
妈妈的心情好，
孩子才会有安全感，
我也感觉是这样子，
那我纠结要不要回去生活的一个就是孩子，
我感觉他会想爸爸，
然后就是我，
我我嫂子他们明年生孩子嘛，
然后我妈妈呢，
也想把我们弄到一起照顾，
就是也挺麻烦的，
你你看你自己啊，
现在你又能挣钱是吧，
然后我想为了这么好的政策，
孩子每每个月还有千把块钱的补助，
然后孩子以后慢慢慢慢的这个手术也有可能让孩子恢复一个正常的平常人的这样一个生活，
就现在这个状态就已经很好了，
你就是不要回去了是吧，
对，
就已经很好了，
你没有必要再耗在一段那种，
他今天骂你，
明天下跪，
今天求和，
明天又骂你，
又羞辱，
你没有必要回到那样一个话后去内耗的过程，
就是他那种人，
就是跟他生活在一起，
就是很窒息，
很窒息，
完全无法沟通。
啊，
现在状态很好面，
嗯，
啊，
还有一个问题想咨询一下，
就是那个抚养费的事儿，
他非要把那个我现在给孩子存的那笔资金当做抚养费，
他说我必须要把那个用完了之后才愿意一个月1000的这样子啊，
这个是不对的，
为什么呢？
因为国家给孩子的这个钱，
他的所有权是孩子，
你们就是作为大人，
爸爸妈妈该给的抚养费是大人该给孩子的，
这两件事情是两个法律关系，
国家发房子的钱就是孩子，
然后他也给抚养费就是他该给的，
如果他不给的话，
那咱就是该打官司打官司，
反正他也是有收入的，
他也是有工资的。
对，
我是这么跟他讲的，
我说那这是两回事，
这是国家给孩子的，
他说他说他说你就说这个东西是不是抚养费，
是抚养费的话，
那我是不是有权利来支配，
他有权利支配，
只能支配在孩子身上，
只能康复，
为孩子的健康去支付这笔钱，
嗯嗯，
就因为他也黑名单嘛，
就为了孩子没有没有拿那个本本，
他从来没有领结婚证，
是不是，
对对对啊，
那从来没有领结婚证也不影响你问他要抚养费，
他如果不给的话，
你过段时间再打官司。
是说，
呃，
分开这个事情已经明确了，
然后他如果不给的话，
你过段时间再打官司，
要一要一个准儿，
但是我我查了相关资料，
他现在已现现在已经是黑名单了，
我叫他去起诉，
然后强制执行了，
他也就是现人高消费对他来说根本没有什么影响了，
如果是这种情况的话，
他已经是黑名单了，
确实问他要钱，
这个就全凭良心，
那你就等吧，
那等个一年之后，
你说这2万块钱花完了，
实在没招了，
用情理去。
想见孩子，
他想要有父爱，
对吧？
想要给你女儿父爱，
那你就等吧，
等个一年，
你就说这2万块钱给孩子质量花光了，
没钱了，
只能这样，
只能通过情理。
我感觉这个是个死循环，
就是反正每个月也会有1000多，
然后现在也有2万块钱，
就是一直扣不完，
他就是不想给，
那你也不能因为他一个月那1000块钱，
再把自己和孩子置于那样的内耗的环境当中啊，
就是说没有这一个月他给的这1000块钱咱们也能过是不是啊，
咱们也能考虑过好是吧，
然后那如果他不给你1000块钱，
他又是一个黑名单，
虽然说在法律上可能我们没有什么办法，
但是在人情上的话，
我们就别让他看孩子呗，
嗯嗯，
是的，
他最近打电话什么的，
我都让我家人拒接了啊，
我就如果我现在回去，
是不是就属于纯属在往火坑里面跳的那种。
是，
那我就懂了，
嗯，
好好过日子啊，
然后在婚恋这一块，
假设将来再遇到什么合适的人，
不行的话，
你再回来再问问龙飞姐，
看合不合适，
嗯嗯，
好的好的，
谢谢龙飞姐姐啊，
拜拜。
其实刚才连麦这个姐妹她的情况，
嗯，
还算是挺好的，
遇到了嗯比较通情达理的父母，
也遇到了一个很好的嫂子，
很很善良的嫂子，
如果这个嫂子是在屏幕前，
呃，
真心的啊，
就是觉得。
向这个嫂子问好，
谢谢你那么善良，
看到了一个女人的不容易，
看到了一个孩子的这个，
这个叫什么难处，
愿意那么善待他们啊，
非常感谢，
真的挺好的啊，
就是她，
她娘家和包括娘家的嫂子人都是很善良的人，
那么她回到娘家生活可能会有一些小摩擦，
但不至于有那种内心的煎熬，
你大家同意吗？
但是他如果说跟他的那个嗯，
男的生活在一起的话，
这男的就想起来了嘛，
就想起来嘛，
贬低你两句，
骂你两句，
没想起来的时候嘛，
又叫什么下跪，
又求原谅，
又这又那的，
他就会生活在一种痛苦的循环当中，
如果说是跟原来那个男的生活在一起的话，
当一个妈妈一直生活在这种痛苦的循环内耗当中的话，
其实对孩子影响特别大，
孩子他不是通过妈妈的表情来判断妈妈幸不幸福，
孩子可以可以通过任何东西都能判断妈妈高不高兴，
幸不幸福。
你们自己有孩子的姐妹认同吗？
就是说你表面上跟孩子说妈妈没生气，
但是孩子能感觉得到你生气，
你表面上跟孩子说啊，
妈妈没有哭，
但孩子能感受到你的痛苦，
所以其实对这个连麦的姐妹和对她的女儿最好的一个呃地方就是当妈妈没有内心的痛苦和煎熬的时候，
这个孩子她才能感受到妈妈的那一份，
就是呃，
快乐，
孩子能感受到妈妈的快乐，
对孩子来说特别重要，
真的很重要。
所以就刚才那个姐妹啊，
首先你就认真的权衡一下，
你如果在娘家待着更开心的话，
咱们就在娘家待着，
至于那1000块钱的抚养费这个事儿啊，
怀柔政策吧，
如果说哎，
一年之后她愿意给，
那就给是吧，
咱还对孩子来说还有个父爱，
如果她不愿意给，
她都不愿意给钱，
你要去父爱干什么？
他都不愿意给钱了的话，
就是对孩子来说也是一个就怎么说呢，
也是一个解脱啊，
别让孩子心里面老纠结着要对他爸好呀，
就这那的啊，
有一天孩子长大了，
发现他爸都不愿意给抚养费，
孩子也是一种解脱，
你知道吧，
道德上也是一种解绑。